your penis has not been socialized and
it doesn't know how to act in the
left-hand light
can I have my sex workers my right-hand
light my religious leaders I will say a
statement if it is true for you
walk forward if it's not true do not
step forward stay where you are
sex work can have positive effects yeah
does sex work can have a positive effect
are you serious like in a in a society
where we're not having conversations
about sex like of course people are
leaning on someone that can guide them
yeah and like that means porn that means
like that means sex workers so many
customers come into the club and they're
just like they just want to talk
sometime yeah they want to talk about
sex with someone and talk about their
sex life like yeah and be like open
about it and like explore maybe like the
things that they can explore with
someone else a lot of people do look up
to us and lean on us for assurance or
some kind of something to hold on to
because maybe they are that lonely in
life that they don't have interactions
with people I literally have a fan that
emails me every single holiday and I was
like oh my god this guy's actually
someone that's a little bit like
emotionally or physically underdeveloped
that's amazing that sex work my sex work
gives him something to look forward to
and that's what sad is people don't
think of people like that that are on
the skirts of society they also love sex
and they want that interaction as well
even with like it within marriage is
like you need to learn different
techniques you need to learn like how to
roleplay you need to like that's why
marriages fail because you are not happy
you're not having sex like sex is a
great way to connect
[Music]
in my own personal experience with porn
it just tweaks my chemistry man like to
where I'll be walking down the street
and see someone be like why isn't that
girl taking her shirt off like that's
supposed to be what happens now because
I'm missing sex education well I don't
think so for me it's that my mind gets
used to a simplicity of it all and for
me sex is available I'm married I'm
married to a great woman that's willing
to party and so like it's not for art
and party with our bodies and so so for
me it's not all I got to figure out how
to get this like it's it's there and
that's the only place that's ever been
for me I don't maybe it's it's like
drinking is totally fine for some people
not an alcoholic
maybe I'm the alcoholic with porn that
just it tweaks my mind in a negative way
that it makes me go man I don't want to
be thinking about these people I'm
encountering like that I just want to be
able to look at them as humans instead
of like thinking about people and how
they couldn't provide for me so I feel I
feel like that the extreme frustration
is the demonization of porn without
actually offering an actual alternative
that kids or adults of any kind can look
towards first real sexual education you
can sit here and talk all kinds of mess
about porn and say that it's bad and
it's damaging but what is actually
enriching there's nothing any sexual
behavior is okay with consent
and let's go ahead and like get out of
the way like we're talking about
children oh I'm talking about people
that cannot have consent or animals
because they cannot give consent I have
some people that want to do some of the
nastiest freakiest things and I'm not
into it but being a sex worker like I
love being able to do that for them you
know I like to be put in those
situations where I'm now like the one
that might be uncomfortable and have to
figure out why I'm feeling this way and
how I can come out doing a good job I
will say I'm interested to see you
sitting up walk up because I've
counseled couples that are like married
for a long time and sex is a problem
like a huge problem I do this like
inventory sheet like oral sex yes yes
you know no no and right and whenever we
got the but play like the guy is my know
I mean guys can't even take their own
partner sometimes just being like I want
to
yes mess with your job my standard of
sex I feel like I've surrendered to God
to my understanding of God in the
scriptures as best as I understand them
and so for me if there was consensual
like you said if there's 12 people like
that's not okay for the standard of life
that I have like said I'm gonna live by
this standard of holiness and
righteousness that's not a judgment on
anyone else that's me saying that sex
even if it was consensual I don't think
would be okay if somebody came to my
church and said hey we want to start
swinging I would say that is going to
destroy marriages man and that's a high
ethic in my church I actually have
counseled people through divorce from
affairs you'd have to ask them
specifically I don't remember it being
shame but adultery
that's not stats that's bad that's not
concern yeah the other person that's
being y2 is not consenting to the third
party being a part of that relationship
that's that's cool the standard that we
that I come at it from and you guys can
say that you disagree with the standard
but when the standard is that I believe
God says this sex is for this couple
this married couple then we step outside
of that we can we can go what about this
what about people that aren't married
not deserve sex you know what well
according to the Bible to get from God
so now that question but again maybe
literally why people are desperate to
get married and rush into marriage is
that marriages because they feel that
sex is only sanctified through marriage
or whatever okayed and they are married
to whoever and they have whatever kind
of sex or they get cheated on that's a
really sad scenario my god I'm not for
everybody but people you know my hopes
is that we finally start living as a
nation and don't put Christian values
philosophically like it doesn't have to
be a new religion but just
philosophically shift our mentality
forward from this old book there's a lot
of assumptions happening right now I
resonate so much with this idea of why
are we going off of this book heck yeah
I'm right there with you sometimes I
read stuff and I'm like holy moly
I need to exegete that passage I need to
understand what that means because if
I'm gonna teach on this I better know
what the heck I'm talking about if they
don't understand the culture at the time
of the audience that was being spoken to
or written to then it can be taken out
of context and so there's a lot of study
that goes into it but with that the
statements that you're making just in
the past couple of minutes or really
blanket statements of let's just throw
out this entire thing because it's
devaluing my work or it's coming against
and though I would agree if you look at
it at face value 100 percent romantic
connections make sex better
some of the best sex I had is like I'm
so surprised by you - romantic
connection makes sex better yeah that
feels very universal sure yeah
absolutely I love having a discussion on
sex about sex with people that maybe
have had not even maybe tons more sex
than me
because I've only ever had sex with one
person like that's it and we we've
gotten like good at each other but
that's it
Wesley hang in there bud I think it's
beautiful and so there has been in my
marriage transactional sex just like hey
man I I need to I need to have some love
right now and then there's been like we
go away for the weekend and there's
notes and there's gifts and and it's
better in that context for me so I'm my
wife's first but I've had a lot of
partners and I just I don't know it just
hasn't been a satisfying compared to
having it in the context of my marriage
sex is better because it's in the
context of like this person that won't
leave me like she's disloyal just commit
it and we get to do this thing called
sex first thing that came to my mind and
now it makes sense why you don't want to
watch porn because you've only had sex
with one person for like of course you
don't want to watch it because the penis
has a mind of its own I want your penis
has not been socialized like a dog you
have done that because that is a whole
nother level of commitment that I'm
never willing to go down you know I have
had sex with partners where I've like
have literally looked into their eyes
and have like felt like that that thing
that has talked about like that
connection that
bonding of like the souls I've cried
even while you know having sex but to
say that it has to be romantic for it to
be better I think is being overzealous I
would prohibit my child from doing sex
work as an adult child that's an adult
yes sorry can use another word besides
prohibit I would not be okay with my
child doing sex work my mind was doing
the same thing yours was prohibit what
like what's that mean disown no I
wouldn't disown not love them absolutely
not
all I would do is just say it's it's not
what I would want you to go that's not
what I would want you to do it'd be hard
for me because of my own view of sex as
being a sacred thing and in my own
personal world not wanting it to be a
show for others when two people have sex
there's a soul tie that is created our
bodies are you know emotional spiritual
physical and so is sex you know it's I
give people this example it's like if
you take two pieces of wood and you glue
them together and then you try to pull
them apart will they come apart yeah if
you're strong enough they'll come apart
but they're still gonna be glue or
pieces of wood on both sides and that's
that's what I would explain or kind of
define as a soul tie there's always a
piece of that person with them and that
is a that is outside of religion that is
just a belief that I see in the in
humanity to me my heart would be sad for
my child I would be burden to my heart
would be burdened for them
I think the reason why there is so much
fear with someone going into the sex
industry are they going to get mixed in
with the wrong crowd is there gonna be
drugs it's a lot of fear based and my
parents tell me all the time that I'm
changing people's views in that small
town in Texas because now they can see
someone who does sex work and is a porn
star and is a family man and this loving
and is spiritual and know it makes sense
to me why you wouldn't want that and I
would love some dental too because sex
work is real work damn it and I need to
be compensated do you think you want to
go down on everybody that is a job they
do so I obviously would come to a
context where we're like we think of
like that dark like came just beating up
like their hoes and things like that
just the drugs the sex right like to the
best of your knowledge like what percent
all of you the sex industry is that I
think we have to then ask the same
question what percentage of your
industry is not truly living their truth
and their life and are they sleeping
with women or boys let's take the
Catholic Church for example like let's
really have this conversation I mean of
course there's people that are bad in
any in any industry in any position and
I wouldn't know that percentage because
I don't associate with those kind of
people regardless of where I'm at if
even if I'm out it at a bar having
drinks I'm not over there doing Kiki
Kiki and staying up all night getting
[ __ ] doing you know math now there's
some porn stars that might be doing that
but that's not for me
I have a sexually satisfying life
am i having the best 100% sex that I
want no because threesomes aren't
happening orgies aren't happening me
getting to hook up with the people that
I'm fantasizing about at any given
moment isn't happening my ideal sex life
is this all ends in an orgy that's my
ideal sex life okay
that's reality so am i living my best
100% sex life no because I'm truly held
back like 70 percent of the time and I
only get to have as much as is
consensual porn has released me from a
lot of my insecurities it has opened my
eyes it has finally made a good-looking
white man marginalized to see a
different point of view I used to be
terrified to speak up and have a voice
and to say what it is that I want or
need and now I am equipped with knowing
how to do it knowing how to approach it
and yeah my life is completely happy and
I'm having a lot of sex sometime mostly
with myself just a little handy handy I
step forward because I feel like I mean
might once again I got it just me and my
wife but she brings the heat and we have
tell you this I can tell you this
because we're very modest people when
she sees this she'll be like there's
half of her that will be like
[Applause]
acknowledgement that's why I stepped
over it man
[Applause]
ready
[Music]
hey guys this is John from Jubilee
thanks for watching this video let us
know what you think in the comments
below and be sure to click Subscribe sit
over here or over here over here